welcome to Hannity all right tonight a
lot of ground we're going to cover
including the president's new executive
order more lawlessness shockingly in
Seattle but we do have video that will
shock you from a gruesome assault in New
York City and much more tonight we begin
with some good news my heart's not as
troubled how do you like that
good news we need good news it looks
like tonight we can say that a robust
v-shaped economic recovery might looking
good be underway
according to brand new numbers look at
this retail sales in the month of May
broke all expectations rising by nearly
18 percent now that's double the most
recent forecasts and it is the highest
monthly gain in the history of the US
let me repeat that that is the highest
monthly gain in the history of our
country now it's now very clear as more
than ever that in 140 days you we the
people we face a pivotal moments just
saying that to mark Levin on his radio
show this is a crossroads election
capitalism socialism peace through
strength appeasement open borders
sanctuary cities sanctuary states secure
borders government takeover of industry
and or confiscate and confiscating
wealth or free markets and energy
independence and constitutionalists on
the bench a lot at stake in 140 days now
we're going to continue to also make
economic progress with the president's
pro-growth agenda and we will or we're
going to descend into the always
predictable always always always a my
new book live free or die I go into the
failures of socialism
we're they want to repeat what we know
will fail and a simple abacus or
calculator would show them that but they
don't care how did Obamacare work out
for you now as we countdown to election
day ask yourself this question in
Biden's four plus decades as a senator
eight years as vice president what did
he ever do to help improve the lives of
you we the American people all Americans
what a Joe and Barack do to improve
police-community relations when they
held the highest offices in the land for
eight years they improve
relations after the riots in Ferguson
Missouri ask yourself did they improve
them after the riots in Baltimore
Maryland Freddie gray did they improve
them by inflaming tensions Cambridge
police and many other incidents nope of
course not they fan the fan the flames
rushed to judgment they vilified police
officers and in case after case after
case their rush to judgment was wrong
and as for solutions what did they do
nothing and by the way you think about
this to Brok Joe they'd do anything to
improve the quality of life for
Americans especially minority Americans
that live in some of America's biggest
cities run by Democratic governors and
mayor's for decades and decades did they
improve the school system at the end of
the obama-biden administration guess
what third highest per capita spending
city in America Baltimore in Baltimore
they had 13 public high schools that had
zero students proficient in math zero
meanwhile and Obama's hometown we
watched the violence all throughout the
eight years who is president violent
crime exploded and he barely mentioned
it like a few times that's it did he do
anything no in 2009 to 2016 4,000
Americans were murdered in his own
hometown City the Windy City so many
thousands of others injured in virtually
every major liberal city in the country
we see a similar trend not hard to
figure out
violent crime way up in Los Angeles New
York way up Minneapolis way up crime
spiraling out of control in almost every
major democratic run city and state but
unlike Barack and Joe finally we have a
president that is willing to take action
we're going to compare and contrast the
president's full record of
accomplishment coming up tonight but we
start with the president's brand new
order on policing by the way things that
Joe and Barack never did take a look
Americans believe we must support the
brave men and women in blue who police
our streets and keep us safe Americans
also believe we must improve
accountability
increase transparency and invest more
resources in police training recruiting
and community engagement that is why
today I'm signing an executive order
encouraging police departments
nationwide to adopt the highest
professional standards to serve their
communities they are great men and women
when others run away from danger police
run straight into harm's way often
putting their lives at stake to protect
someone who they don't know would never
even met
now with this executive order today
President Trump is increasing police
accountability with a nationwide
database that documents excessive use of
force claims by the way impactful in
both the Floyd situation and what
happened in Atlanta both times the order
also sets guidelines for police
transparency it bans the use of choke
holds unless an officer's life is at
risk then you know guess what
all holds part to save your life during
their eight years in office Barack Joe
they didn't do it one of these things
not a single one
and unlike Barack and Joe president
Trump is actually well he's talking to
everyone incorporating all sides into
his policy decisions and earlier today
even one former Obama official actually
had shockingly surprisingly but
rightfully praised for the president
take a look there were a number of
families there who spoke directly with
the president with barr attorney general
Barr and also with Tim Scott and all
those law enforcement people who were
there listening and they basically just
told their stories which apparently
according to people I talked to do there
were tears and you know I think the
president was kind and gracious to them
I think it was good that there was that
did not turn into a big photo op that
did not turn into kind of a big media
moment that was more of the process of
trying to move this White House forward
and I think those families feel good
about having had the chance to tell
their stories to the people who have a
chance to make a difference listen I I
agree with the level of frustration of
the the peak that the pieces that are
being put in place
now are not adequate but they are in the
right direction also is more than Barack
and Joe did now not everyone was happy
with the president's executive order
Democrats accused him of not going far
enough why didn't you say that the
President Barack Obama and Vice
President forgetful Joe Biden and the
media mob they were upset that race
didn't play more a more prominent role
in the order moments ago White House
adviser J Ron Smith responded to that
let's take a look at what he said can't
really fix the heart of people but you
can fix individual pieces that deal with
the real problem which is access
opportunity if you talk about the police
force you know it's about having a
police force that represents the
community when you talk about education
it's about access to education we talk
about access to capital access to
capital and those are the things that
we're really dealing with by the way as
the president says at the end of his
rally as he crescendos we are one
glorious nation under God we are one
American family all of our citizens all
of you we're one family we're all
important I believe all children of God
that's why President Trump well that's
why he passed prison reform that wasn't
Barack and that wasn't Joe it was
President Trump who got nonviolent first
offenders out of jail again not Obama
not Biden it was President Trump who
offered clemency remember that moment
two years ago Alice Murray Johnson that
was not Obama
that was not Biden it was president
Trump will pardon Angela Stanton King
not Barack Obama not Joe Biden was
President Trump who massively increased
funding to historically black colleges
and universities again they had eight
years Obama Biden did nothing it was
President Trump who developed a special
tax free Opportunity Zones in low-income
neighborhoods again Joe and Barack they
did nothing it was President Trump that
oversaw what was the greatest economic
surge for every American demographic all
Americans that was did not happen just
the opposite happened under President
Obama and the forgetful VPP Joe Biden
after
in Americans Hispanic Americans Asian
Americans women in the workplace youth
unemployment african-american youth
unemployment record low unemployment
after record low after record low now
preacher ona
but look at the early numbers things are
bouncing back quicker than I thought
they ever would it's President Trump
who's getting back on the campaign trail
to connect with voters in person at
rallies it's not Biden his Terry becuase
I'm fine with him staying in to stay in
he's fine he only sees two people that
day's two body guys let him stay in the
basement he's terrified apparently to
live in his house oh by the way there's
some and the mob and the media and
others they don't want the president to
have a rally they're gonna they got to
go with a lawsuit I read it I said okay
that's there's a simple solution just
call it a protest nobody will complain
the claiming that the president's
upcoming rallies of putting lives at
risk
but of course they had zero problem with
the mass protests all over the country
the past two weeks many Democratic
politicians even the ever well closed
down everything governor Whitmer of
Michigan he even participated
well maybe the president just called the
rally a protest then everything's fine
the media won't criticize you you could
call it a protest against socialism or a
protest against the well forgetful Joe
either way as the election nears it's
important to ask who do you trust to get
the economy back on track
they failed for eight years let's see
losed let's see 13 million more
Americans on food stamps 8 million more
impoverished labor participation rate
since the 70s lowest homeownership rate
in 50 years worse recovery since the 40s
and accumulated more debt than every
other president before them combined Wow
and it disproportionately impacted yep
minority communities who do you trust
who will you trust to fix America's
cities who do you trust to improve
policing and then the unrest and do you
trust the ever confused Joe Biden who is
been in the Washington swamp what has he
done in 40 years he has little to show
for it
you trust President Trump will moved at
lightning speed to make the country a
better place and kept his promises that
was refreshing and
hundred and forty days I'm beginning to
feel the urgency I can't decide this
election but you can you the American
people you will be the ultimate jury
your decision will impact this country
for decades to come
and I'm saying based on what they are
saying and proposing that we all know
that it's failed this country will be
unrecognizable in my opinion for our
children and grandchildren if god forbid
they win I wrote a book it's coming out
August 4th go to amazon.com Hannity calm
reason I wrote it is because this is the
tipping point this is the moment
everything's at stake here this is not a
game you want the country freedom and
liberty that's the country that will be
existing under Donald Trump you want the
country of failed socialism
you'll get that under forgetful Joe